[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to the what
podcast i'm very with me is lord taco
you'll notice again missing is brad brad
is still moving into his new place in
new york city for his new job they moved
from new orleans to new york and i
understand just a couple of days ago the
furniture
actually arrived i think you got that
word too didn't you taco that's correct
it looks like they got everything they
needed so
yeah i got a facetime from them the
other day and they were sitting on a
cushion and on a wooden floor yeah in an
empty house so
you know we we try not to pick on with
as we've said pick on him but brad's not
with us today
um but we've got another great show i'm
very excited about it we have talked
about doing this for
years
and definitely this year but that's to
have somebody on who can speak to edm
music electronic dance music
we have admitted freely admit we'll
continue to admit it's just not our lane
i don't think i don't think either one
of us has a dislike
um
you know any opinions like that it's
just not something that we listen to a
lot right
yeah and like you said that's what we do
we go to the source when we want to talk
about something and that's that's what
we did this week
yeah and we'll get into that and i want
to thank kyle for
joining us um
he's a friend of yours and you'll hear
about how we got kyle and why we got
kyle and all that in a second but i
wanted to i want to go back to something
that we talked about two weeks ago when
brad was here in chattanooga as they
were moving and actually came by uh the
world headquarters here and we recorded
down in studio one
and uh today i'm in studio two because i
i've had a little uh
little medical thing and not going up
and down stairs so i've adapted so i'm
upstairs if you're wondering
you know why there's a strange backdrop
ground behind me but uh
we
we talked about a couple of things and
and a couple of things that happened
since that i wanted to kind of to bring
up and i've really thought about it if
you remember taco two weeks ago we kind
of were asking the question because
we're hearing rumors
that ticket sales are not great
for bonnaroo or for not that's not right
they're not selling out let's put it
that way i don't know you know they may
be close they may be 90 they may be 80.
um i don't think bonnaroo is
um
but as we have said and and you had on
your t-shirt two weeks ago never not
great that's where that whole expression
came from that's right the 2016
festival was the lowest uh attended
number
and we all agree or at least brad and i
agree i don't think you were there that
year it was one of our favorite ones
yeah i wasn't there but i've heard that
from a lot of people and a lot of people
are saying yeah they would love a return
to that level of uh you know 2016 where
it's just less people and less crowds
and
just just easier to get around
exactly and and i guess what i wanted to
uh was was to say
um
is while we were talking about that i i
think it was i just want to point out
my point was it just feels like a reset
here it feels like a lot of
people dem
fans uh the people going the people
putting it on
everything or just trying to
figure out where we are
and i i think that's normal but
um
i was listening to well
kyle is a long time goer been going
since 2012
he's a friend of yours you met
there at bonnaroo
uh brad and i have been friends uh since
camping together we were not friends
before we knew each other so it's
bonnaroo that has connected us
you and i are connected because of this
podcast and bonnaroo i didn't know you
before nope um
you just spent the weekend down in
huntsville with daniel and sharla host
of the real rewbuss
podcast yeah
that podcast didn't
didn't exist a couple of years ago we
have become you know internet friends
with uh jake and uh
and parker of the the ruhem guys that's
right a third
podcast that
is dedicated primarily to bonnaroo
we're all friendly uh like each other
very much you hang out with darla daniel
and charlotte quite a bit
yeah i was just down there this weekend
that's right and uh
pondo our guest last week
uh
we communicate with through reddit and
discord and and whatever else
that and
i was listening to uh daniel and
charlotte's podcast last week and they
were talking about what we were talking
about and sharla as she has said many
many times i go for the community the
the lineup and the music are secondary
and
i just i just wanted to point that out
that
you know
i think that's so real and it's amazing
to me
that this whole community exists
um
and it goes way deeper than just casual
hey i'll see you in a year
you know
uh we all talk year-round oh yeah and
that's i think that's really cool
is the point i guess i'm trying to make
and and while
while this may indeed be a reset year i
think it will be a good year
and i think it will reset and will come
out stronger i don't it's not a
it's not a doom and gloom i don't
see that at all i think it's just a
figuring out
you know what the next step is yeah it
needs to happen and you know look the
last two years you talked about we go
for the community well there's been no
bonnaroo's for two years but you know we
still threw together many ruse we still
had our own gatherings because that's
what we missed was the community we miss
the people so yeah the lineup is great
and all the other activities are fun but
you know that's that's what keeps us
coming back
it's a shared thing and it's a shared
attitude we talked about it with pondo
this idea why can't it be like this
year-round
um i mean that's very real to me
um
like i said but
you me and brad are our friends uh we
talk regularly because of this show
you know we have some things in common
but not everything you know
um
so
and it's all because of this not the
show the festival
um
no
we talk because of this show but it's
the festival that brought us together
and continues to keep us together it's a
festival that inspired all of this
right and our and our first guest is
another great example of that um
and we get into it with him the edm
thing
surprised some of us that we had been
going for years you know why would
bonnaroo
uh take a tire one of their larger
stages one of their larger tents and
dedicate it entirely to one genre of
music
it wasn't our genre our favorite but it
made perfect sense to me and the more we
all thought about it it continued to
make sense and uh and it still does and
and kyle i think uh does a great job of
of addressing that so
um oh yeah
i i guess that's it anything else before
we before we bring him on i don't think
so let's just get into it
let's do it all right here's kyle
and he's going to tell us uh he's going
to give us some of his picks for some
edm acts house acts dubstep acts all the
different genres within edm uh some acts
to not miss and uh
so here we go here's kyle
[Music]
kyle thanks for joining us so much on
the what podcast
absolutely all right so we i want sev i
want to do several things with this
episode today
we promised uh taco you and i and brad
we have talked about for years about
doing this we've and that we just never
have
not for any good reason
uh we just never have um
i want to establish a couple of things
uh
a lot of people are probably wondering
why you know why kyle how did we get
kyle on the show it's a fair question
i was wondering that this morning myself
how was i going to answer that
it reminded me
taco
you remember i think it was this was the
occasion when we were in knoxville
in the offices there at ac entertainment
talking to uh
stephen and brian about how they booked
booked the shows
and um
i think it was jack johnson was that one
we asked about how jack johnson got got
on the lineup do you remember that
uh and then the answer was he answered
the phone
there it is
[Laughter]
we we sent out our crack research team
our producers all those people and who
can we get to talk about edm
on an episode of the podcast because
brad
taco and i admit freely that that's just
not our that's not our lane
um not at all and i want to be very
careful i'm sorry not at all and that's
you know if we've gotten any criticism
it's because of you know we just don't
have any expertise there
yeah and it's fair
i think it's very fair and uh
because of that i want to
what i also don't want to be uh
you know is is the old guy you know you
kids get off my lawn i don't have
anything against edm i like
of the three of us i probably listened
to the most of it or used to
yeah i was always a big
i was a big fan of uh the dj or the the
guy that we you know whose name we no
longer mention because he's such a
horrible person
but i loved
his music
girl talk i love so i mean of the three
like i said i think i probably listen to
the most but i don't claim to understand
it
and i've i've told the story many times
when they converted the other tent to
the other stage and brought in edm i i
was sitting in our camp with our good
friend mike dewer
at two in the morning he said man we
gotta go see this and and we wandered
over and the three of us i mean mike's
older than i am i'm 58.
um denson went with us he's i don't even
know how old denson is he's one of those
guys he could be 20 he could be 120 yeah
but the three of us are standing there
and all these kids are running around
and rabbit costumes and
you know glitter and whatever having a
great time and
and they kept looking over their
shoulders and at one point i thought man
we're pretty cool to be here and then i
realized no they just think we're narcs
and it's the truth hello fellow kids
hello kids
don't pay attention to us we're standing
here staring at you three old guys
um and they were having a great time
it didn't buy me
so what i want to do is
i want to let kyle do way more talking
than me
um about this because
this is something you love and i want to
know why and i think
taco does too
but i also want to make sure to
understand that we're not coming at it
we don't dislike it it's just not our
it's just not something that we listen
to a lot so
um yeah and i guess to set the stage
kyle is one of my friends uh known him
for years and 2018 was my first bonnaroo
and i went with kyle because we were in
pod two together he's got a van again
i've got the bus so you know we parked
right next to each other looked great
got a lot of people come by and see
everything so we get out and set up camp
and get situated and then we pull out
our schedules to compare no it's like
what are you going to see what are you
going to see i don't think we saw a
single show together because everything
kyle was interested in there was no
crossover with what we were interested
in so it was like
for the rest of the weekend i just saw
him he was coming back to camp we were
leaving or vice versa so
uh yeah
yeah
that's awesome so that's terrific he is
exactly who i thought of when we started
talk about we should get somebody on who
knows a little bit about edm yeah
all right so
kyle
to help even further set the stage tell
us a little bit about yourself where are
you from and how long you've been going
to bonnaroo
from south florida grew up in colorado
raised in
in atlanta uh first bonnaroo was 2012 as
a as a high school graduation gift
um and then didn't go again until 2016
when i got the van in 2015
and then from 2016 on i haven't missed a
single one so it's what five years six
years now something like that
so okay so it wasn't edm
uh that originally brought you
no no um you know i grew up going to all
the different festivals my dad took me
to concert since i was like you know
he's sleeping up on his shoulders and
walked through the pit with me and like
you know here we go like just part of
life
so you know once bonnaroo came around i
never even been to like an electronic
show ever
and all i took was that one that 2012 i
think like subtract played that year
um
really when i think of 2012 like all
that sticks out my head's like ludicrous
the chili peppers and like subtract and
i remember being at the subtract show it
was in one of the tents and the base was
so low the sand was like coming off the
ground like up to your calf and like you
couldn't breathe and your shirt's
vibrating against you and i just knew
like oh this this is a more immersive
experience in my opinion just like
you're feeling it you can't help but
feel it just everyone's so excited great
time so yeah so yeah
go ahead
no yeah um
yeah so yeah that's it it is it
that's a great way to put it it is as
much a feel thing as it is a um
anything else thing right i mean you
just yeah yeah you're feeling it you're
hearing it the visuals you know and then
you know of course all the people in the
crowd through all their light up toys
and they're doing their flow art this
guy's got fire and they've got leds and
you got the glove people and all that
it's just it's just so much fun and
everyone's so i mean that's festival
life in general just everyone's so
excited to talk to you and you know
share stories but
in those crowds i mean everyone's just
so such a tight-knit community because
we're all there for the same thing you
know
so that's one of the things that i mean
i i again that show that we went to at
two o'clock in the morning i mean i get
it
again it's not for me um
in some ways but i get it to me it's
like the perfect festival thing
i mean that's the whole idea is to just
sort of let yourself go and be who you
want to be
and
lose yourself i guess i mean
right
absolutely absolutely uh over the last
summer i went to a couple i went to
infrasound family
reunion festival up in uh minnesota
which is all based music all edm
and i went to sound haven in tennessee
which is not too far from manchester i
forgot where in tennessee it was
um
you know there's three days of of a
whole festival just dedicated towards
edm based music dubstep
house dmb all that kind of stuff
and that was just a whole different
experience i'm used to going to bonnaroo
where it's like it's such a you know
such a mixture of everything and there's
people from all walks of life
and these festivals
still all walks of life but just kind of
narrowed down a little bit more you know
a lot of dudes with pashminas around
their necks and you know the harem pants
and just like you know everyone's got
the toys and all that it was just such
an interesting experience going you know
comparing those to bonnaroo
and honestly i mean even after going to
those i would still prefer bonnaroo just
because of the
how different it is i mean you know like
like russ said and we went to the same
festival
yes none of the same people
like he showed me these names i'm like
is this the same lineup like where did
you get this copy of the schedule yeah
it's like we were talking two different
languages
trying to communicate seriously
seriously wow you've raised so many
things that i want to get into and just
to let people know one of the things
that you did and i very much appreciated
i'd asked uh
taco
to ask you to send
uh some names and you put together some
playlists um so that i would have a clue
what we were talking about and i wanted
to hear it and and you did that thank
you very much and i think we we can link
those uh
uh
on our on as part of this show we sure
can so people can listen to it
um
and
people will be surprised at the
diversity i mean this is definitely
i was thinking about this this morning
all genres have their perceptions
you know i mean going back to when i was
a little kid my parents were even
raising us my brothers are older than me
you know the big knock on the beatles
was it all sounds the same the big knock
on elvis was it all sounds the same
you know it's too wild it's whatever
all of the same criticisms of edm
there's nothing new it's the same stuff
so
um
when you hear these playlists you're
going to hear a lot of diversity you're
going to hear a lot of talent
the one question that i will say and it
it took me back
uh
going back to that that night when the
three of us wandered over at two o'clock
and watched mike asked a question about
some edm music is there a beginning a
middle and an end
and i got no answer for that one
[Laughter]
but i mean does there have to be you
know
uh right right again we you know we came
up with songs that had a middle
beginning and an end but you know maybe
there doesn't have to be but the knock
like you know it's the same song for 20
minutes or whatever i mean
we've heard that about the grateful dead
and humphries mcgee you know yeah fish
fish my gosh yeah so i mean i'm not
going to go there
um
yeah
what was it
going back to my point
i'm we're going to ask you in a little
bit to name you know give us your picks
of of the bands to don't go see
um and i'll go ahead and ask you now so
you could be thinking about it uh you
know maybe wonder what are the uh entry
level you know what are the acts that
people that are going to bonnaroo who
know nothing about you know who are the
ones to go see that that maybe are good
entry level good examples whatever and
then
you know what are your picks uh we'll
we'll get into that but uh
i'm
curious and i'm so glad to hear
all the other things you said
the fact that you and taco would compare
schedules and be like you know what
festival are you seeing yeah
is exactly right
that's a great thing about bonnaroo and
a great thing about festivals in general
but you also mentioned
that you've gone to some of these
here recently that are more fine-tuned
they're more you know the lanes are
are pretty defined
um
what do you like about those and what do
you maybe don't like about those how are
they different
oh i liked about them uh
do you find so much i mean you find new
music every festival you go to bonnaroo
is known for that you know you you're
walking across and you'll hear something
crazy you go check them out now you're a
fan for life um but for these more
fine-tuned like the edm festivals and
stuff
it's more of like from your neighbor's
perspective they start turning you on to
stuff like they'll be playing music out
of their
car or whatever you're like yo man like
what is that and they tell you and all
of a sudden you've got a whole new
person who died they might they might be
at the festival they might not even be
there but just a whole new person to
dive deep into
uh me personally you know i love deep
bass and like walking through the
campgrounds and it's just constantly
just
wubs coming from everyone's different
little spot let alone the main stage you
know down the hill and all that it's
just like
it's it's like your music almost like to
me you know that's you know that's what
the genre i prefer
um
it was just so cool like walk around be
like wow like everybody here is in tune
to the same thing
but everyone has different tastes you
know like i said it's like there might
be the kids over here playing house
music where they're just you know
they're just partying you got the dudes
over here playing the real grimy nasty
dubstep where people are just like you
know head banging to the floor you know
you never know what you're gonna what
you're gonna hear
and it's you know it's it's really cool
um
really other than that i mean it's just
the music is the main difference but the
community's still there i mean it's a
festival everyone's still there to hang
out and help each other out still a
camping festival
you know everyone's still trying to like
lift each other up and show each other
new stuff and all that kind of stuff so
um
as far as like you know things i dislike
compared to bonnaroo i really
i don't really i can't really think of
anything smaller stages you know smaller
festivals have you know one stage
smaller stage they have renegade sets
usually you know out in the campgrounds
and all that so you go find those
um but i mean bonnaroo kills it as far
as you know having the multiple stages
and the tents and all the different acts
and all that i mean you can't nobody
beats that you know in my opinion so
so yeah
if you can
what's the difference between house
dub
edm
that's an old man question i get it i
mean i can hear i can hear the eye
absolutely but maybe maybe i'm not
i was expecting this question i knew
this question was coming all right so
you got you know edm's the umbrella
right you know it's the electric dance
music that's you know that just covers
the whole the whole realm uh you've got
house music which is you know kind of
what you hear more in like bars and you
know kind of just more upbeat you know
students name that type thing um you
know you've got dubstep which is a real
you know more deep little darker grimier
uh you've got uh you've got german bass
which is the more upbeat kind of house
where you know it's a little bit more
european inspired but now it's starting
to make a
a big wave here in america which is cool
it's been trying to do that for a while
um you know you've got the pop edm stuff
like like on this year's lineup you've
got like
said the sky elenium griffin closey like
people like that they're a little bit
more you know a little bit more slower
you know they ramp it up they bring it
back down
um
you've got trance you've got i mean
there's so many different sub genres of
edm in quotes
um
that you know it just it just breaks
down so far and that's just like the top
there's like the ones that i listen to i
mean you could ask somebody else and
they'll tell you seven different ones
so you know you never know
but um
but i mean looking at you know this
year's bonnaroo lineup um
you know this i made a list here on my
phone i keep looking down at
and i also have a list of 20 20 and
2021s line up on here as well
and i will honestly say that
this year for bonnaroo i i refer to it
as house uru this year this is houseroo
i mean you've got we've got 16 house
acts we've got 16 house acts we've got
like nine like base acts and then you
got like some poppy stuff
and you know the years before that we
didn't get to go to i mean it was like
17 hard acts of like real you know real
talented uh not saying almost talented
or nothing but like real darks type of
stuff which is what i like
and this year just kind of became
household i mean i don't know if house
artists were easier to book
or what happened but we've got so many
house artists and which is cool you know
that's fine but i mean you know it's
just to me it's like yeah you know all
right get into that first of all
taco anything you wanted to ask before i
i mean i'm i'm i'm dog dominating here
no go right ahead okay um
so i'm glad to hear you've been there
since 2012 so you've seen the
development for for us
uh we've been going brad and i anyway
since 2007
uh there i think
he was either eight or six i can't
remember he was a year before a year
after but um
we were a little bit surprised when they
converted the other tent to the other
stage and and dedicated it to
uh edm
um were you at all
okay no i thought it was a great move i
mean and now that we don't have collide
thank you for saying it correctly i'm
glad you pronounced it correctly
oh you have to pray out no people say it
wrong all the time it drives me crazy
really um
yeah no yeah now now that the client is
gone it's like it kind of left a hole
you know now we have wear in the woods
which are they're trying to fill that
hole i feel like with wear in the woods
um because there's djs on this year's
lineup that aren't even playing inside
of cineroo they're just playing where in
the woods big names like nightmare and
stuff like that so
um yeah losing calliope that was like a
huge hole that opened up so then they're
making the other become the other
instead of the other tent just the other
yeah made a lot of sense and you know i
think they can definitely expand it a
little bit more as well i'm kind of
hoping this year they've added a little
bit more sound to it i think it might
need to be a little bit louder but maybe
that's just me
i don't know man i can feel that bass
all the way into my tent when i'm
sleeping at five in the morning but
it's still hot it's not enough
it wasn't edm but i'll never forget i
was in the pit shooting photography for
uh my morning jacket and they opened
with uh
um
oh shoot the uh
is it victory dance
from the one two out anyway it was just
one of those bass notes and my whole
chest felt like it was exploding and i
looked at the guy next to me and he said
he said photographer next to me said i
think i just peed myself
so i know that bass feeling that you're
talking about and i like it i like it a
lot
um yeah yeah do you so
you thought making that transition was a
good idea and i have to agree it
certainly worked i mean they went from
you know 20 was it 16 where the audience
the numbers were way down and then the
last couple you know obviously up until
the pandemic were sellouts and they were
on their way to sellouts they obviously
knew what they were doing
um
do you back to the whole your schedule
versus taco's schedule do you just go to
there or
do you see okay no you do see other
shows no yeah
oh yeah i mean you know i'm the one
thing i don't really i don't listen a
lot of country i just not wasn't raised
that way you know it's not really my
thing but i mean oh i i cover the whole
spectrum usually you know and you know i
i'll find myself gravitating back
towards you know the base stuff just
because i know a lot more of the artists
but i mean i was you know raised on you
know rock and roll and hop and you know
and how even my dad back in the day used
to bump techno music and take me to the
techno tents at the the vans warped
tours and the buzz bake sales and all
that back in florida so
you know i've i'm pretty well versed
just the comments
everybody has their stick everybody has
their thing man
i'm not a big fan of new country and
i'm good for about three bluegrass songs
right right let's just add hell yeah
it's the same song just fast faster and
faster you know it's
right you know and people can say the
same about edm or whatever
um when you do go
is it one set
a couple i mean are you there all night
it depends on what else is going on
other stages i mean if there's nothing
else that's going to pull me away from
that then i mean it's fun to stay there
for three hours four hours however long
you have sunrise sets or whatever and
just get lost in that whole world and of
course the longer you stay the work the
harder it is to walk the next day
because your legs are just shot from you
know your neck your back your legs it's
like you feel like you just got hit by a
truck
um but it's fun that's the part you've
got the rest of your life to
but
recover
yeah exactly exactly
right
that's right
i get it and i've i've joked about it
for years i mean i'm the i'm
they make fun of me i'm that go to bed
early i don't go as bad early as they
think but uh i'm the guy that gets up
with the sun and i can't tell you how
many times i've been walking to get my
coffee and you know the the edm show is
just ending
and everybody's got that
zombie look and i'm like it's just gonna
get worse for you
your day is about to go real bad
uh
it took a lot of people having a great
time you know
cool good for them
um yeah you like this year's lineup
i do it's bonnaroo you know i like the
lineup no matter what um
compared to the last two years that we
didn't get compared to
i'll be honest i mean all the lineups
i've been to this one's the worst in my
opinion you know not even just from an
edm standpoint but just you know overall
i like going through the lineup
like i said there's 16 house artists and
like again not bag on house there's
house guys out there i love house it's
got its place but i mean to me i don't
know it just seemed like but from what
they gave us the past two years it
didn't happen
and now what we have now again going
back to because you go to other
festivals do you think it's because the
others have pulled
is it because there are other options i
consider that
i consider that yeah i don't know i have
no idea i mean
maybe maybe that the you know the more
experimental and the the darker uh the
deeper artists and stuff have been
pulled over to more niche festivals
that's totally possible
um i mean yeah but it's like looking
back you know at the last year
uh you know we had people yeah like uh
tipper tipper's massive i mean he does
these these crazy visual shows
uh people like ls stream same thing we
had dead mouse uh subtronics which you
know heavy rhythm stuff
uh trip street not low eighty aliens i
mean sudden death yeah there's gonna be
a tipper tipper was on my list
that was the one when i did my okay my
dive
it's like okay that's the one i'm gonna
go that guy you go to for sure
right right yeah tipper i mean uh tipper
will have the tipper and friends i
believe it's in sewanee and they'll do
the tipper and friends festival and it's
just like you know he hosts it type
thing he's got a bunch of other people
that play it i'd love to go i haven't
been yet but um he's a cool dude i mean
i love his sound and he's very very
artistic guy and then his visuals alone
i mean my god
it's i don't know how he does it
so yeah um
i'm glad to hear all this because i
think some perception i know there were
some perce and again it's perception
but there was a perception among some
that bonner had become the other and
then the rest of the festival you had a
large group of people that were just
doing
edm
and there may be some may have been some
of that i mean who knows what this year
was is going to be like
um
i don't know if that was fair or not i
mean i you know i don't know too many
people that just
dedicate themselves to one thing
it's it's kind of anti the whole purpose
of bonnaroo or the beauty of bonnaroo so
but i know they were right
but sometimes sometimes the lineup on
the i mean like i said the last last
year
uh when i was looking at the lineup i
said to myself oh my god like i might
spend the entire weekend at the other
like it was just such a stacked lineup i
was like these are people that i want to
see so bad that i like i was like wow
i'm going to spend the entire time in
the other stage which should be okay but
you're also missing out on you know on
on the rest of everything else that's
going on
um what's weird this year too is
you know if you go day by day
there's no
and i i i say heavy bass that's you know
that's why i refer to like dubstep and
stuff like that just like you know
experimental heavy kind of stuff we
don't get any of that until what sunday
saturday halfway through saturday so you
got thursday friday and halfway through
saturday until any of that stuff even
plays
i don't understand how
i understand how that lineup you know
happened you know i guess they're
filling the rest of it with house music
which is you know house music is great
for like day stuff you know you're being
dancing around everyone's having a good
time you know you can dance with a hot
dog to house music you can eat your food
while you're dancing totally cool you
know no head banging no nothing like
that which is fine
but halfway through saturday until you
get something that's really heavy that's
really going to shake you besides
recknow recknow plays thursday
and you know so we got one heavy guy the
first day nothing nothing nothing and
then from saturday on you have the rest
of them and even then it's like okay
seven artists
and so i don't know it's just weird i'd
love to sit down with the bonus folks
and just
like maybe we need to revisit taco we
need to get brian and stephen back on we
we do we need to make another trip to
knoxville and ask him ask them those
questions when you guys
when you guys talk to them that's what i
was like man i wish i could be in the
room right now just so i could speak up
and be like yeah quick question
well i think it goes to the question too
about it had the other festivals
influenced um you know have they taken
from have they
have they
i don't want to say
given up but
acknowledged maybe that there are
boutique festivals
for just that i mean is the demographic
so
defined now
that that's what they have to do um i
have no idea and it wouldn't be just for
that genre i'm i'm wondering about a lot
of it
uh to be honest we talked about that two
weeks ago and uh don't know the answer
we won't know till it's all over said
and done and
and everybody evaluates but uh
all right exactly either way we're all
going
great i mean you know never not like i
said
it could be the same artist the whole
weekend and i'm still going to go you
know it's like it's never not it's
amazing um
all right so who are the who are the edm
acts that uh
when when taco and i and brad are making
our lists and and brad ain't gonna go
let's be honest he ain't gonna get
anywhere near the other stage unless
he's walking past it to something
you know
um
but who who do i need to definitely
don't miss
um
definitely don't miss yeah who's the
don't miss
act on the other
i'm gonna say and again these are just
in my opinion um of the trees you know
great experimental artist i mean real
just real funky vibe uh g jones is a
classic very these are more kind of like
experimental dubstep type situation uh
black tiger sex machine i remember when
you guys were going through the lineup
and i think one of you guys were like
what is a black tiger sex machine i have
to know what that is i'm like in the car
just laughing like you guys you're
missing out on so much
um you know for house music you've got
like donburski and abstract and
shipwreck
you know they're pretty solid house
artists that are more on the industrial
side which is what i kind of lean more
towards to versus the poppy side
uh you've got closey and flume and
griffin on the more
the more like middle ground you know
flume gets kind of hard sometimes you
know
uh
so yeah i guess those are like three
from each sub-genre that i've got listed
here uh you've also got um who we got
still woozy we've got raven schoon for
the people who want something heavy 100
drums that girl kills it i mean to her
it's amazing lucy same thing uh what
else we got here
uh i guess mark ripley doesn't really
count he's doesn't he's not really in
the edm thing but i mean if nobody
should miss mark i don't i know you guys
are probably going to see
they threw together and it was just like
yeah we gotta go it was great it was
great so jealous i mean his live streams
got me through the hand yeah seriously i
mean just so much fun to watch that guy
i got a kimono just for it
fair enough
and i said the acts that are just on the
other there are edm acts throughout the
festival so i i shouldn't have i
shouldn't have limited that that way
there'll be some on the witch
um
right and like i said too oh yeah yeah
we'll probably be on the witch you know
that's a big name probably on the witch
like i said you know they've got a
they've got nightmare out on the where
in the woods stage which will be crazy
because i mean he's not even playing
inside of cineroo he's just strictly
playing right out there
and so you know a massive name like i
remember one time me and my dad went to
bonnaroo a while back and that was his
favorite show and he still to this day
talks about the visuals that nightmare
had in the background i mean he compares
that show he compares every show to that
show and so you know
you know very very talented artists and
all that
um
it's just weird it's gonna be cool to
see how that works where
he's just going to stay outside and
everyone wants to be inside and so i
don't know it's it's interesting i think
you guys spoke about it last time how
there will be i think uh pondo was
talking about the different acts yeah
that would be on the campgrounds and on
the different
plazas so it's interesting it's a great
all right what are the uh what are the
acts the uh
that have you
interested what are the uh
discovery acts for you
on the
list hmm
i mean
like i said the people i just said like
you know of the trees g-jones all them
uh
other than that i mean we still have the
whole hip-hop side of bonnaroo you know
we've got isaiah
chattanooga guys this is his first
mixtape yeah
absolutely absolutely um you know you've
got like people like you know japanese
breakfast you know everything uh you got
lane eight you know which will be great
uh
femi couti which is more of the like
whole like earth type stuff sons of
commit which is
um
the comment is coming that's the that's
two of the guys two of the guys or one
of the guys from the combat is coming
and it's not just like you know
saxophones and drums and just like
having a great great dance time
um you know you got mark ribley got
ludicrous got lettuce you got you know
all these such a wide variety so i mean
my list is just all over the place so
you know like the couple people i told
you earlier as far as the edm stuff you
know that's what i'm excited to see uh
res g jones of the tree ravens coons uh
of the 100 drums
stuff like that
uh not again not for the house people
i'm not ignoring the house music we've
got chris lorenzo we've got uh phantoms
got shipwrecked all these people you
know i love them
um
and then i just you know the pop stuff
like i said griffin close the elenium
porter robinson said this guy
you know if if i'm if it's lunchtime and
they're playing you know i'll go check
them out you know just to say i've seen
them but i'm not really going to go like
seek them out because that's not really
my thing
so
yeah
and then as far as hip-hop as well you
know we've got you know j cole's been
massive i can't wait to see jay cool i'm
a huge fan you guys talked about him on
your last podcast saying that you
weren't too impressed if i remember
right they weren't too impressed with
the show that he put on back then so i'm
hoping that now he's that was however
many years ago he's gained a lot of you
know
notoriety since then i'm hoping he puts
on a great show we've got boss playing
boss is part of his label so i'm sure
they'll come out together and do
something
um
yeah and then really there's not a lot
of hip-hop this year either which is
something else i was interested in
kind of lacking there as well do you are
you a
solo guy or you got a crowd when you go
50 50 sometimes i'm solo and sometimes
i've got i think this year i'll have a
group but like the festivals i went to
over the summer the tennessee one and
the minnesota one took the van by myself
and just made a little road trip out of
it and decided to go make friends which
is i mean it was my first time doing it
and it was nerve-wracking absolutely you
know because but but i was also going
into it knowing how camping festivals
are and like you know what once you hear
that first beer can't pop open from your
neighbors and then you walk over with
your with your beer can and now it's
like hey you ever tried this i'm not
trying i'm glad you said your beer fries
what do you mean neighbors beer can what
i was confused there for a second
yeah kyle's a weirdo like me because we
both actually enjoy camping year-round
you know outside of festivals too right
yeah um
the reason i ask is you mentioned the
show and and i'm not going gonna get too
deep into this is where i definitely get
into the weeds of
you know it's one of those perception
things with like a dj show the show is
what lights and
you know a guy standing at a turntable
kind of thing but once you see it and
hear it and you're part of the crowd
and you're with friends you you get it
it's a little bit different than
uh than going to a concert and sitting
in a chair and watching so
it's an experience i mean i do know that
um
like i said i get it i i have no
you know it's not
necessarily my thing but i like it um
for a bit so i'm anxious to go by and
see what they've done
and see some of these acts and i very
much appreciate you putting together
those those playlists i've been
listening to them for a week
yeah it's good stuff i mean cool you
know that to me the whole not the whole
to me one of the great things about
bonnaroo is discovery i mean that's
been the absolute absolutely driver from
the beginning
and community and everything else but
discovery is a huge part of it
and uh
i always say like when the lineup comes
out and i don't recognize a whole lot of
people that's more exciting to me
because that means i'm about to discover
way more people than i knew before yeah
that's why this whole show
i mean there's no question about it so
right yeah i don't want to go see the
same thing i've seen and heard over and
over and over i want i want to leave
there with a new favorite act if i leave
there with a new favorite act it's been
a great festival
uh that's that's mine and yeah if you
can turn me on to somebody
you know or i can turn you on to
somebody it's an even greater festival
so
that's the
exactly exactly that happens all the
time like the the girl i mentioned
earlier 100 drums when i went up to the
festival up in minnesota
i was talking to my camp neighbors they
drove there from colorado and i was
asking them who they're excited to see
and
she was there strictly for 100 drums and
i didn't even know who that was at the
time you know like i listened to the
spotify playlist that the festival had
put together beforehand that had
everybody in it but you know there's so
many artists on there i didn't get a
chance to really like listen to
everybody
and you know she she demanded that i go
with them to the hundred drum show and i
mean instant fan i mean when i saw her
on this year's lineup i was so excited
because she's just she kills it and it's
just little stuff like that where your
neighbor might convince you to you know
oh you've already seen that person eight
times go check out who i'm gonna go see
and then you go see him and it's the
best totally worth it so
all right
taco any other questions
i think i think that about covers it
yeah for me i i don't have them too much
to add i hope we'll do this again um
maybe with some more uh experts to help
fill in the blanks for the you know
our obvious uh things we don't know
about but kyle
very very helpful i i'm so glad you did
this and uh
i especially appreciate the fact that
you've been there you know
for for many years and have that
perspective
so this has been very very helpful in
some great names and
again the the spotify playlists are
great uh
and we'll link them hopefully we can all
yeah we'll we'll link them hopefully we
can all meet up for a show or two yeah
absolutely
all right and uh
barry who on the spotify playlist
yeah i mean
there was i can't remember there was one
or two others because as i was
i wasn't matching name for song
you know what i mean i was just
listening so there were a few that i
would go back and say all right who is
this
and
yeah that's why at least for you guys i
try to you know i made three different
playlists yeah i'm glad you did the
darker stuff and sort of kind of give
you part of where i asked that question
the difference they are different and uh
i mean i i knew that and i but not
everybody does
um
like i said you hear adm in some
people's mind and their perception is
whatever it is
and it's like everything else it's way
deeper and
more nuanced than you're given credit
for so
all right man thank you so much
yeah hey do you want to shout out your
instagram where can people find you and
all right cool cool i've got two i've
got the kyle gonzalez which is just me
on instagram then i've got my van who's
way cooler than me that's the steely van
so he's got his own page i got my own
page
um i also want to give a shout out to
bonnaroo give a shout out to you guys
also bonnaroo please add one more
mushroom fountain just like one more
fountain
like please like it gets hot out there
like i remember like i was we watched
the like 2018 it was the internet
playing in a tent middle of the day
middle of the crowd even the internet's
up there like freaking out on how hot it
is and i mean people are passing out and
that you know passing out but they're
gonna be taken care of and everything
and the whole time you look over your
shoulder and there's that fountain just
flowing in the background and everyone's
like god i don't want to leave this but
look at the fountain
so more miss tints another fountain
would be awesome
um other than that bonnaroo you're
beautiful you're perfect
[Music]
all right so there you go
i thought that was great i thought kyle
i was so glad that uh he'd been there
been going for years so it wasn't like a
one-off
not that there's anything wrong you know
but he was able to give us some some
history and some nuance and some
background
um
and he also goes to a lot of other
festivals i just thought that was really
cool yeah it was great yeah and if
you're like us and you look at some of
these names or genres and you're like i
don't know what you know hopefully i
definitely got some uh some pointers and
some ideas so there's definitely some
shows i want to check out now after
after talking to him
yeah it's funny and brad and i have
talked about this i think we've talked
about it on the show you know brad's a
radio programming guy and i've i've
written entertainment for a newspaper
for 33 years and one of the big hurdles
that that i had to overcome and he has
too is this notion that when somebody
says hey have you ever heard of uh you
know whatever
your inclination is to say yeah sure of
course yeah you know you get burned a
lot of that and
one of the
i finally realized
no i've never heard of them and i'm not
going to apologize for it there's just
no way that you can know everybody no
you know
it's funny to hear
people look at you like well how can you
claim to know this or that if you've
never heard but you can't know everybody
so i'm not even gonna try yeah and on
this show we've never claimed to know a
lot about this so
yeah not this particular genre
yeah so that was a huge help for me i'm
glad we had them on
yeah it was great i hope to get somebody
else on with maybe some other opinions
um absolutely and maybe someone within
the within the industry uh you know
maybe some artists and acts
um we need to do that but uh
all right well this isn't the only
festival uh going you've got one coming
up this weekend right coming up this
weekend will be shaky knees downtown
atlanta georgia and that's this will be
my second one we i went last year and
you know it's a city festival so it's
different than bonnaroo uh the camping
is really like what gets me into
bonnaroo so having to you know ride the
train and uber and go back and forth
it's it's not as fun i don't think but
i looked you know i left last year y'all
asked well would you go back and i said
uh really depends the lineup would have
to be really good well guess what the
lineup is really good so here i am i'm
going back
yeah it's good and
i i
as i've said uh i've had a couple of
medical things
that i'm recovering from very well not
complaining i'm lucky very very lucky
but uh not going to be able to make it
but this i'm with you man this is a
great lineup are you going all every day
every day yeah uh friday saturday sunday
friday's green day saturdays nine inch
nails and sunday is my morning jacket
yeah there it is that's the one that
kills me that hurts me
sundays are really good i think they're
all three great lineups i i would go
yeah all three days
um
if i had to pick sunday would be it for
me
um but i'm i'm uh i'm happy for you
you're you're
you've got
a family friends that are close right i
do but it turns out they sold their
house and moved out to uh woodstock so
they're a bit further out of the city
than you know to stay but i've got
another friend lined up that actually
uh kyle that we just talked to he and i
and christo that's what i'm saying with
carista's also got a bus
so you know we're all friends so he said
he's got a house just down the road from
the festival he said come crash and i
said okay there you go didn't you go
last year and uh
and take like a
three hour walk
to go in
10 minutes
yes that was uh yeah so uh
kelsey that i went with uh after
after the festival got out this was like
saturday night one of her friends was
there and he said all right y'all we're
going to this bar i know this great bar
it's just a couple blocks down the road
so we start walking and we're walking
and we're walking and like an hour goes
behind i'm like where how and he's like
no i think it's just further up here
and you know we eventually just stop and
sit down because he can't figure it out
we look up where it is and it's still
like you know a couple miles away so
we're like we're gonna uber from here
wow so but that that exhausted me i mean
that was far too much walking just for
just to go to a bar
i could have got a beer just about
anywhere i know we passed so many places
i'm like this place looks cool can we
stop here they got beer can we go here
wow
well there i mean again you're going
with the people you've met because of
these these festivals
exactly i don't think
you know i think we're past it i know
four five six years ago whenever i would
tell people i was going to bonnaroo the
first thing was always you camp
and we're so far past that now it's um
there's just this whole community thing
and it's
it it's country-wide it's not just you
know
within our our own little universe so i
think that's really cool
yeah i'm looking forward to it and uh
what are we up to for bonnaroo like 50
something days yeah yeah it's right on
top of us yeah it'll be here before we
know it and uh we've got more shows
planned we've got uh
i'm very excited i don't know how i hate
saying what we've got planned because so
many things can happen but i will say
this we've we've got a guest lined up in
the next couple couple of weeks who was
uh was there at the beginning uh when
bonnaroo was created
and is very much involved in the
festival industry and i can't wait to
have him on as a guest
coming up very soon and then we need to
get more people like pondo and kyle and
uh
and anybody else we can think of
i agree i mean i i this has been great
we've reached out to you know some
friends of ours that said hey you want
to be on the show and they said yeah so
it worked out great like we've said the
uh the vetting process there's my cat
the vetting process is pretty stringent
um you know they answer the phone call
that's usually uh that's right
[Laughter]
all right well taco
unless there's anything else i want to
say thanks to everybody and i can't wait
to see everyone and uh thanks so much
for listening and hit you know we never
say this but hit that subscribe button
and tell your friends
we never push it very much yeah um
it really goes a long way to help with
growth of the show and to to get us out
to other people that might not have
heard of it so we we really appreciate
it yeah and thanks to consequence for
pushing us and
that helps a lot and
if you want one of those never not great
t-shirts
go to that merch the whatpodcast.com
it's on there
buy a t-shirt and i'll send you
something from the basement i promise
maybe i'll send you that cap
[Music]
if the package is moving the cat's in it
i better go before she backs my leg off
yeah all right let you attend to that
thanks guys so much
[Music]
consequence podcast network